top gun maverick the action-packed
dogfighting thriller starring tom cruise
recently set its place as one of the
highest grossing films of all time
bringing in over 1.3 billion dollars
worldwide and this might actually be
impressive too
if it wasn't stolen
from star wars people seem to love top
gun maverick and it certainly shows in
the critical response with a certified
fresh 96 rotten tomatoes score and
record-breaking box office numbers when
i saw the film i loved it too but i
couldn't help but notice the fact that
they completely ripped off the story
from the original star wars
roll the intro
[Music]
before we get started here's a spoiler
warning for top gun maverick we will be
talking about lots of spoilers in the
film so please wait to watch this video
until after you've seen it if you don't
want it to be spoiled in this video
we're going to go over how top gun
directly copied star wars down to the
plot characters and mission as well as
why it was so successful even as a
complete rip-off in essence i'll explain
how top gun maverick stole 1.3 billion
dollars by copying star wars but first i
want to say that i love star wars so
it's no coincidence that i also really
love top gun maverick and i'm not just
saying that because of its similarities
to star wars the film actually had a
fantastic story with great character
development and high stakes throughout
the entire movie one of the biggest
things that stuck out to me though was
no not miles teller's mustache no what
stuck out to me was the great attention
to detail tom cruise is known for doing
all of his own stunts so it should come
as no surprise that every dogfight scene
was filmed in actual f-18 fighter jets
that means no green screens and no cgi
the actors actually had to train their
bodies to prep for the forces they would
undergo in the f-18s tom cruise wanted
to make sure his fellow actors were
ready for the experience of flying in
the high caliber fighter jets seen in
the movie so he put them through a sort
of boot camp before filming commenced
according to miles teller we were all
mini toms making this movie he put us
through i'll just call it a tom cruise
boot camp we were getting in killer
shape and also for the stunts and stuff
that tom does in movies it's usually a
very specific type of training you're
not just going into the gym and lifting
some weights we did flight training for
three months before we started filming
we got put through the ringer they even
underwent training in an apparatus known
as the dunker where the trainee is
blindfolded and dunked underwater before
being spun around where they have to
find their way out it's this kind of
training and level of attention to
detail that really sold the movie for me
and for many other people too but i
still couldn't get over the pretty
blatant star wars imitation throughout
the film for starters the characters in
star wars and new hope and top gun
maverick are eerily similar they both
feature a young male protagonist whose
father died when they were children with
rooster as the protagonist and top gun
and luke skywalker as the protagonist in
star wars they're both watched over by
an older man who eventually trains them
this mentor was also best friends with
their father and can be found in the
characters of maverick and obi-wan
kenobi in each of the stories the
protagonist wants to follow in their
father's footsteps and they become one
of the best pilots in the world or the
galaxy later in the film they're engaged
in a super dangerous mission to destroy
an enemy weapon of mass destruction
whether it be a uranium refining
facility or a world killing death star
their missions both entail a low
altitude high speed trench run made in
an effort to avoid anti-aircraft weapons
both have to hit a small ventilation
shaft but i will say that we found our
first difference between the two movies
because rooster's ventilation shaft is 3
meters wide while luke's was just 2
meters wide before taking their final
victory shots both main characters hear
their mentor speak to them telling them
don't think just feel or to use the
force and trust your feelings which is
basically the same thing so they both
take their final shots with no guidance
technology and save the day lastly the
film's arrogant pilot hangman and han
solo comes in at the last minute to
shoot down the final enemy pilot and
saves the main character the number of
similarities between these two films and
their plots is astounding also just look
at how similar tie fighter pilot helmets
look to the top gun helmets i mean come
on with all of these similarities it
seems pretty obvious that top gun
maverick is a direct replication of star
wars a new hope the film's director
joseph kaczynski even said i think when
jerry bruckheimer made top gun star wars
was definitely an inspiration for them
so it makes sense that dna would carry
into ours so how exactly are they able
to get away with directly copying star
wars when their director is even saying
that's exactly what they did and the
answer because it's actually a really
good movie probably one of the best of
tom cruise's entire career it had an
exceptional cast great writing a
well-executed series of character arcs a
high attention to detail and it reminded
people of one of the best movies of all
time star wars while it's certainly not
the type of movie you think of for a
revival of the original star wars the
creators of top gun maverick still did
an exceptional job putting it all
together it's honestly kind of a miracle
that the movie exists and it's a miracle
it's as good as it is top gun maverick
is a sequel to a misty-eyed campy 80s
action movie that didn't really warrant
a sequel it's been 35 years now since
the release of the original top gun and
i don't think anyone was expecting that
we'd see tom cruise in the cockpit on
the silver screen ever again but here we
are with tom cruise at almost 60 years
old it's shocking to see him flying
under the immense pressure of an f-18
but then again we've seen him do crazier
things in his mission impossible movies
including flying through the sky
attached to the side of a world war ii
aircraft and holding his breath for over
six minutes while filming a scene
underwater
he truly is a fantastic actor with a
high level of dedication to his work and
it certainly shows in top gun maverick
regardless of whether the movie took
some pretty heavy inspiration from star
wars but i'd like to know what you think
how much do you think top gun maverick
took from star wars drop your thoughts
in the comment section below also check
out the video on your screen for some
more of my content don't forget to like
and subscribe and thanks for watching
rocket riley
[Music]